if you're just joining us rudy giuliani
is sweating his face off explaining to
us why trump really won the election
again inspectors
every state
almost every approved this
is thrown away
gone for eternity is this a skit the
only thing left is to have been a dead
person
that could have been not filled out wait
he's saying there was a dead person in
the envelope
rudy's about to have actual drops of
sweat coming off of his brow i mean is
this a normal amount i don't know how
hot it is in the room but this something
seems very wrong here all being the
lawsuit that comes out duty is melting
arizona is a k is a state that we're
looking at very very carefully strongly
looking at it i would say we're probably
i assume
she's working if she's working for them
i'd like to read them all to you but i
don't have the time
you should have had the time and energy
to go look for them
your job
like it's my job to defend the president
i don't represent the president
michigan wisconsin
is he bleeding did you see is he
bleeding from his ear what on earth was
that
does that hair die just to look at the
lawsuits in order to do it it looks like
blood
but in the material oh my god it's
everywhere ten
thousand at least
and we're getting he's got to get off
the stage there are other aspects of
this fraud now the morning of
development someone's got to get him a
napkin they were going to count the
these this new kind of battle
i've never seen anything like this
what on earth it's getting onto his
shirt now again and it was conch any
jury would accept because they heard
this evidence
that somebody had this plan
maybe that was always the plan
it looks like sap from an oak tree or a
maple tree it looks like someone's
making syrup should the city describe
that to you oh my god it's all over his
face
he's gonna need a towel dealing with
chill evidence i don't know guys it's
sounding like trump won isn't it based
on this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
moment of the sexual experience would
ask the young lady who's your daddy this
should be remixed if officer akimov is
watching
this could be the next remix masterpiece
dude because just wait till you see what
happens here oh officer officer akimov
is here uh that's beautiful
who's your dad i'm joined today by
pastor james david manning
oh i'm a christian
[Music]
who's your dad i'm joined today by
pastor james david manning
[Music]
a long-legged mcdaddy is the most
successful pimp on planet earth to
reverence the word of god to trust it to
preach it to teach it
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lies
what happened in prison that brought you
to jesus
what happened in prison that brought you
to jesus
[Music]
watch singer and george bush jr have
been penetrated by at least 100 men in
their anus a hundred thousand two
hundred thousand strong i didn't do it
that's not my problem oh i got down on
my knees
[Music]
and tons and tons of lives loads and
loads of money and tons and tons of
lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
let me say something to you about
marketing
[Music]
starbucks has done the exact same thing
that coca-cola has done except they've
done it we've seen them
that certainly seems to be a story that
has been missed
[Music]
all right welcome everybody wow look at
my appearance today it's a crazy crazy
day it's so great to be back i will
explain everything it's been so long but
yet it's like only a day has gone by and
i'm wearing my new nerd glasses and just
everything's happening it's all crazy
this was by far
the most triggering vacation to the
audience that i've ever been on
every time there's a vacation there is
some portion of the audience who will uh
threaten to cancel memberships who will
say i'm never watching again david what
are you doing we don't get a vacation
and you're taking vacations and all
these different yeah all these different
crazy things okay
um but this one was particularly
triggering because we had
guest hosts during the break we had
farron cousins of ring of fire we had
jesse dollamore and it was even more
polarizing some people saying
you should not even host anymore
other people should host your show
and it's like well just go watch their
shows then they already have a show
but i got so many beautiful emails
from people who
seem to almost like value the show
even more and i'm going to read one to
you right now this one is from
i'm not going to say the name because
it's a very unique name it might it
might be clear who it is
and they said
i was intrigued by the feedback you
received while you were on vacation
i asked myself why was your absence on
your most recent vacation almost
literally painful for me this guy was in
pain because i was gone
uh compared to previous i was one of
those who thought i mean listen based on
previous vacations where there was no
show
perhaps a guest host would dull the
sting of your absence
and then they go on to say
uh
the this is not a knock on your your
hosts your substitutes were great but
then came the epiphany what you provide
in your show
including the live streams
uh and member content is irreplaceable
it sounds cliche but herein lies the
breakthrough for me
you could have the best guest host ever
and it simply will not do i'm
speculating that perhaps i never
realized this before because you never
had a guest host i realized only so
recently that you offer something so
unique that folks like me
became very dependent on it
and i also think perhaps many of us
could also take also take your regular
appearances a bit for granted it's
almost like a microscopic addiction that
you don't appreciate until it's gone
anyway this is a beautiful beautiful
email and uh i will be sending them
money as a thank you because it's very
useful for me today
but um no in all seriousness it's great
to be back
and uh i don't know what else to say
about the break i mean we're just you
know i'm i'm back and it's basically um
it's basically it okay
cepha hyde exactly so we are on the
brink here uh this is like a warm up
did you guys see that that light just
went off
i heard a click and that it's all it's
blacked out
i think we're just gonna have to do the
stream like this that's happened before
with that light
um
[Music]
it's weird we're gonna we're gonna keep
looking at that
um
so anyway this is like a warm-up stream
i have a ton of stuff to catch up with
um
i have new mango material
i have photoshops i have memes i have
voicemails i have super chats
so many so many different things
but this is a marjorie taylor green matt
gates rally this is all a warm up
because saturday night trump goes back
to rallying there are people who believe
and i hope you'll all join me on
saturday night
there are people who believe
that uh trump will be reinstated as
president at the rally in alabama on
saturday why they believe that i have no
idea i mean it makes no sense
uh there's no there's no reason that i
can imagine
uh why anybody would believe that i need
11 000 votes give me a break yeah
um but uh that's gonna be saturday but
this is sort of like a warm-up stream to
get uh to get everything going again so
where to start
first of all
i wanna make sure i thank people that
are already here and supporting we have
dropped to a pathetically low i don't
even know if it's legal for me to stream
at 774 twitch subs but i'm doing it
but i do want to say thank you to life
is good the old tired road the mike
lennon shorty short brief not tenuous
chill sd nug wrangler sam the sleaze bag
as well as sling blade and dirt knap for
uh re-upping their twitch prime
subscriptions that's nine also very very
special chris schweitzer has just signed
up at joinedpakman.com and christopher
speaks is a new member putting us
already at 11 which is a great place to
be this early in the stream let's look
at a few super chats mike pillow was
right about august reinstatement it just
wasn't trump it was the taliban
david i'm curious if you know or heard
about rudy giuliani joining cameo i have
not heard about that
will says when will trump respond to
questions about running in 24 2024 but
that's hipaa
yeah maybe soon
kyle downey says it was cool that jim
gaffigan filled in for you yeah jesse
dolimore and jim gaffigan have a similar
look that's for sure
robert says hi david love you brother
welcome back great to be back
cyrus palmer says i see farron all the
time jesse was new i liked him and i
like having guest hosts over no show
that's the consensus
david sir missed hearing you oh hold on
i need to have my sir material queued up
sir you're on the cover of time magazine
again david sir missed hearing you and
your villains while you were gone did
fine glad you are back congratulations
sir you just won the election denver
says welcome back sir sir sure
do you do the new york times crossword
and if so do you have a favorite from
the standpoint of day published i don't
i haven't done a crossword in a really
really long time
a thanks to the anonymous gifter for
gifting five subs on twitch also thanks
to it's me john b
as well as napa skip dog
putting us at 18.
um
i have so much material i'm just gonna
get right into it we i do have one sort
of um
leftover unban request i do have oh why
am i wearing glasses actually the the
reason is not that exciting i'm still on
europe time basically i came back here
uh as many of you know i was uh i was up
in the air sir your wife is up in the
air i was up in the air and i crossed
six time zones in a record
record-breaking speed
and um you basically adjust one hour a
day so like it feels like it's 11 30 for
me right 11 15 for me right now and i've
been getting up at four or five in the
morning just because of the jet lag i'm
like wide awake
i've never taken adderall but i think if
i did it would feel sort of like i'm
wide awake at 5 00 a.m just bing
and um so i just you know after 14 15
hours of the contacts it starts to get a
little a little grating so that's the
only reason
okay let's get into an unban request
a user known as reborn josie
um
was banned
some of the messages that they
uh sent include
poor people get vast the elite collect
off everyone's fear whatever i'm one
person
i'm still alive i worked in the grocery
store during all of it i wanted to die
and this fake ass virus failed
completely at that i'm tired of bots
how is vaxxing your kids a real thing
people can support what is even in it
they were banned
their unbanned request is coveted isn't
real
oh i missed
that is a
very very easy perma-ban my friends it's
a hard perma yeah exactly thank you nug
and uh not even making it difficult for
me
so that is it
as far as unban requests go
um
super chat from mcfreeny who says david
hoping you can settle a debate between
my partner and i best clooney film
i'm for the descendants but my wife is
up in the air sir your wife is up in the
air you know i am not a big george
clooney guy but i think the best clooney
movie that i've seen is
hold on it has the word kings in it
kings george clooney it's like a middle
east
what's the name of this movie three
kings from 1999.
i think that that
i mean listen i don't know a thing about
george clooney i couldn't even tell you
other films he's been in
but i really liked three kings i thought
it was very very well done
very well done
okay
let's get to a few other things here
um where to even start oh this is super
exciting
we are now
dangerous let me refresh here we are
dangerously close to one
billion youtube views
i had to pause there for it okay
we're at 989
million
294
thousand
six views
and so
i estimate
that we are anywhere from
nine
to
16 days oh hey well thanks to try hex
for the raid great to see you my friend
uh i was supposed to meet trihex in
person at a dinner
with uh hassan [ __ ]
and molina destiny bonnell iii
and
stephen kenneth destiny bonnell the
second
and trihex and through some situation i
still don't even understand
trihax i guess was coming from three
hours away but only gave himself 20
minutes to get to the dinner
and so the dinner was over
um and i was not able to meet trihex in
person but big fan of trihax so great to
see trihax here um
yeah thanks to the master debater
beaumonix tool fan a pet giraffe marzu
fazu
as well as an uh oh no that's it yeah
for the twitch subs very much appreciate
that putting us at 23.
um but in all seriousness when we get to
the billion views it's going to be very
very exciting so i have two requests for
you we're working let's split up the
work if we can
internally and it's mostly producer pat
but let's call it we we're working on a
billion view compilation
which is going to have some of the best
moments from you know the history of the
show
we will
uh run that when we hit the billion
views again somewhere like 9 16 days
away
i'm asking you for two things number one
billion view related memes videos
remixes songs whatever okay start
getting the material in because i think
that that's gonna be a great thing and
we will we will use those and number two
i would i have this fantasy and if it's
crazy tell me it's crazy i want to have
a compilation
um of people calling into other shows
like if you can get on the charlie cork
show
if you can get on i don't even know who
the hell on the right even takes calls
sebastian gore cuts
or whoever if you can get on the air and
mention david pakman show billion views
in whatever context slip it in be honest
and just say
uh mr gorka sir will you congratulate
david pakman on a billion views he won't
know who i am whatever call any people
on the left right whatever
we'll start putting together that
compilation as well
um of mentions of the billion views
jesse lee peterson would be a great one
to call
um
whoever whoever yeah anyway so if you
get those are my two requests we've got
a couple weeks during which we can put
all of this together i think it's going
to be really great okay so that's the
latest as far as that goes now let me
get
to the mango material okay i have a new
mango element for you now why do we care
about mangoes the reason we care about
mango oh i almost i almost uh previewed
it there we care about mangoes because
of this i don't know how many of you
guys remember this but this was a funny
moment
mangoes my bag of mangoes up under trump
cost me eight dollars i love mangoes too
nine cents okay
now that we are up under our body's
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes mango aren't mangoes like
three bucks each that's it i want what
eight or 11 bucks that sounds good then
the american people belong and highway
robbery is what you're doing that's
right
my mangoes back down that's right
right about that the wisconsin crowd not
identifying with the mango material
don't
raise the price of fruit don't you want
me to be healthy don't you
okay so that's where the obsession with
mangoes came from now listen to this
i read an article on my flight home
about the underground
whatsapp pakistani mango trade
apparently there's an entire world of
mangoes i didn't know about
and i learned it was like a 20 minute
read i learned about this website mango
zz
look at what i i think there might be
something we can do with this
look at the mangoes that are available
on this website
and apparently
the pakistani mangoes are like the just
the tops
and this mango here the chansa i don't
even know i mean look at look at this
look at this wealth of mangoes
apparently the chansa is just like
incredible
the chansa grown in multan is perhaps
the sweetest version of chaucer
available anywhere
mangoes such as fajri
bangan pali white chansa ratawala and
anwar rital are also very popular
varieties
you guys have no idea what's happening
with mangoes around the world
um and so anyway the only thing about it
is if you want to buy these
let me see if i can even do that
you have to buy like crazy quantities
like here's a box of exotic mangoes it's
a hundred bucks and that includes
six to twelve fruit elements
so these are this is expensive fruit
okay but apparently these are just like
the best mangoes so anyway there's a
whole underground uh mango world and i'm
kind of glad to be um
in it in a sense so if people can think
of something we could do with these
exotic mangoes and maybe tie it into
other stuff i don't know
but it's all pretty fascinating all
right so there's the mango stuff
um
people asking is it m-a-n-g-o-s or
m-a-n-g-o-e-s both are acceptable
spellings i actually googled that
because i didn't want to end up
um
in the uh embarrassing position of doing
it wrong
apparently both are acceptable
um
let me see here
yeah merriam-webster lists either at
correct guys it's not a hundred dollars
a mango it's a hundred bucks for a box
of six to twelve manga
exactly
dear god
um okay good all right let's do a few
other super chats just to get caught up
here
um
i'm glad you're back but guest hosts
were amazing been following them wish i
could show you my garden
first you steal sam cedar's backdrop now
you're stealing his glasses
you helped steer me away from right wing
ideas
know you're in mass but thoughts on the
california recall i think there's a risk
that a right-wing nut
gets in in there and it's going to
backfire
missed you while you were gone david but
love the like-minded commentators also
i'd love to see more diversity in the
future yes
sir i enjoyed the bonus show glad to
hear your girlfriend tested so
positively to the negative yeah oh okay
let me talk about that so i did not get
covered i did not get covered that i
know of on this trip i did not get
coveted that i know of on this trip i
tested really positively from the
standpoint of negative okay
however
i did tell a story on yesterday's bonus
show and a lot of people are predictably
misunderstanding the story
um
my girlfriend did have not one but two
positive tests now notice the language
i'm using she had positive tests
the language is very relevant here if
you want to hear the story
bonus or boner show yeah call it
whatever you want
you can just get get a membership and
listen to yesterday's bonus show watch
yesterday's bonus show i may tell the
story on an upcoming show speaking of
memberships because of my vacation
we all missed the 16th anniversary of
the david pakman show that was on monday
monday slash tuesday
and um we we i actually have a leftover
coupon code from the anniversary this is
just an insane spa i can't even tell you
it's it's completely illegal
the code is 16 for 16 all one word and
by that i mean one six for one six
it's we've never done i'm not i'm i'm
not actually kidding here
we've never done a discount this big
these are criminally low rates if you
wanna take advantage and get us up to a
hundred here
joinpakman.com
16 for 16.
twitch subs do not get the bonus show
you've got to be a website member
website member
um yeah 16 for 16. so there's an
opportunity for you to take advantage of
that i would take it because it's an
incredible situation no but i tested
very positively
from the standpoint of negative
carson says staying on topic of your
channel stats your most popular video is
dangerously close to surpassing 10
million views is that true let's see
um
oh no this is the hold on this isn't
even the right channel oh wait a second
guys
the the second channel
is that almost can we get this to 10k
do you guys think we can do oh look at
that
we've got to get our second channel to
10k i think
wait what's going on here
look at that look at how close we are
yeah let me let me check out the uh
the david pakman show
videos
most popular oh wow now 9.9 million
views we are very close to being able to
celebrate passengers whoa our first oh
my god we're only 5 400 views away from
a 10 million view video we have never
had that
this could be an historic day
um
yeah but we i would love so this is the
pacman live channel though we would love
to get our first uh ten thousand there
look at that 150 to go
um appreciate that appreciate that very
much thanks for letting me know
invite louis back on and do a blind
mango eating taste test with different
types of mangoes i like that idea that's
not a bad idea at all
that is not a bad idea at all
people requesting
voicemails
i will indulge that i will indulge that
let's listen to a couple voicemails
so um what i didn't appreciate about um
benjamin shapiro is his fam
like um
i got to know one of his fans really
really well and um he's from italy or
his family was from italy
so i'm kind of seeing how judaism
it was like by the way she called
through the entire vacation i was on
vacation i was flying around i was up in
the air
calling calling calling calling it's
crazy it was like um the enjoyment of
life kind of do
um
so
i don't know like it seemed kind of like
more like
it was basically on repeat
when people call in oh oh oh hold on but
this is a new this collar you've got to
hear this is a new caller okay guys
listen to this
hi david
welcome back
i hesitate to say welcome back because
you might not listen carefully happily
to the following is this bernie
which you may want to respond to
tomorrow on your program
you
spoke
about
biden's
way
of leaving
which was absolutely
positively essential
but the way you
approached your damn emails
was the horrendous way
he left
leaves tremendous
doubt okay so this guy called back this
is my new favorite caller
put another way yeah if this guy offers
you candy
don't get in the van okay your
credibility is terribly bruised if not
shot
because your listeners democrat or
republican and i am a democrat when we
hear
the way you descended
joe biden
and when we hear the way i defended
getting the hell out of afghanistan
okay
30 subs to go on the pacman live channel
before that magical 10k number so
critically
discerning
about so many issues and you did not say
i cannot believe
that 5 000 troops
were removed an airfield was given over
to the taliban
and we see oh my god okay he called back
again
david
what
brightened did
and the way he did what he did with the
troops
not protecting the people of afghanistan
will cost the democrats the next
presidential election
that's possible that i don't disagree
with and then there was one more voice
these all go the full three minutes but
i can't do it to you i can't do that to
you
when people
call in in the next days to come and
they challenge you on your lack of
discernment of
the world most people actually have
agreed with me and said biden was
decisive and it didn't go perfectly but
the longer we stay the more we spend and
the more we ruin there it is folks 10
000 subscribers
on the pacman live channel
we have done it
and we are really close to our first
youtube video ever
with 10
million views if you can believe it very
very important stuff
um all right we'll do a couple more
voicemails
just going through what's going on i had
600 voicemails waiting for me when i got
back from vacation so i was thinking now
that
like a man can be a woman and a woman
can be a man
maybe it would be
appropriate to
illegalize
um
like uh
like massage
i noticed that like some parents um
dear god
few other super chats i now live in the
philippines the mango capital of the
world where did you vacation i was in
northwestern spain in fact i posted a
bunch of pictures from it here is one of
me
having a coffee
and uh this one was
memed very strongly hold on a second
where was it
uh
wait a second where was that meme oh
here we go
somebody memed it here
so there's that
um and then also somebody turned it into
this which i love this is just really
really good
um
just really nicely done really really
nicely done
so that's that
david sir welcome back happy sweet 16 to
the show oh oh my god i there's so many
people that are taking advantage of the
of the sweet 16 special hold on
our 16th anniversary was monday and we
have a code 16 for 16
on my website look at these people
signing up alex finch
seth howard just became a new member
dumps
okay christine gower just signed up with
the code
jonathan levy or levy is a new member
tony zurich has just signed up
jessica cartier big massive dumps
sophie oiberg is a new member number
seven james peterson is number eight
jessica makowski is number nine kyle
hufford is number ten they call them
dumps
robin barnes number 11
and christa zargoza number 12 putting us
at 35
very much appreciate that yeah we did a
big membership special on monday for the
16th anniversary of the show
but because i like you guys so much and
we're all having a good time here it's
the first stream back i've notified you
that the code 16 for 16 that's 1 6 for 1
6. it's the biggest discount in the
history of the david pakman show
and i don't want to skimp on thanking
people over on twitch thanks to tricia
northstar as well as canned caviar
andrew dale
liquid ice
ali's
the wilhelm screen
bone master aj skorpia
light chaser um
oh that's it okay
putting us at 43.
very much appreciate it and we have to
be careful calling it our sweet 16
because this is a matt gates rally today
that starts in about nine minutes and we
just want to be really really careful
about that
uh okay
david do you plan on doing more crypto
coin and exchange ad placements and your
thoughts on has your thoughts on these
advertisements changed
since you started taking them no yeah
i've we've been super clear about it
like listen
we're saying these are sponsored videos
i say in the video
don't do anything i'm not giving you
financial advice don't do this is not a
financial endorsement i've talked
candidly about like guys we're making it
obvious they're paying us if you don't
care about this [ __ ] just skip the video
we're funding the show
you know at this point it's been
discussed so much
that um
no yeah i mean you know i don't know how
many more we have in the uh
in the pipeline so to speak i don't talk
to them at all
you know our uh one one of our team
members handles all of it so i don't
know exactly what's coming up
but um
what are people saying it violates tos
you can't say the s word now is that
what people are saying
what i don't it's totally over my head
what what happened
that did i don't even did something edgy
happen that i said i don't even know
oh the joke of oh my god okay oh yeah
yeah
um
matt gates is a congressman very
professional stuff
sir do you see militia violence becoming
another unsolved problem in the u.s like
mass shootings post 2020 election lie
yes i do
unfortunately i do
speaking of which oh well hold on let's
get out let's get away from that
david sir what's your favorite type of
ice cream cone i like the single cone
you know something i really don't like
guys i have to tell you
um
when i go and i get a cone it's like
there's ice cream everywhere you know
ice cream is just falling out of the sky
there's there's ice cream everywhere if
i go out to a place to a place that does
scoops and they i get a cone i want to
i'm really getting it for there's this
perfect balance between ice cream
mass
and cone where you get the flavor and
the chill of the ice cream and a little
bit of crunch okay
i don't want if i go in i get a little
cone and i want a small or a small as
some say
i don't want two three big scoops where
this thing is like a foot tall
where now i've now i have to either chop
it
or eat a pound of ice cream before i get
to the cone bites
so when i was in spain i went to the
absolutely
most perfect
place where you can say it's the little
cone but do you want want one ball or
two balls right okay okay
and so you just asked for the one and
it's really one uh and i got a perfect
pistachio cone
uh
did it was it or was it double chocolate
anyway
and almost right away you're into the
thick of it you're into the cone it just
works way better i don't need a foot of
ice cream on my tiny little cone then
when it's hot it's melting all over my
hands it's just it's not civilized guys
it's not civilized please
okay
um
everyone remember you have to re-up your
twitch sub every month yes please don't
forget
dear sir i'm a resident and the youtuber
i'm a california resident the youtuber
kevin paffrath
with more subscribers than you is on it
and leading the polls does he have a
chance
he's leading the polls that can't
possibly be
i he he interviewed me he's leading the
polls
somebody can get me a poll i would look
at that
john mccormick says david and all listen
to trump latest interview with hannity
close your eyes he sounds like
christopher walken yeah trump's trump's
eye was swollen shut
it was a weird interview what's your
favorite food in spain
oh just just i think the grilled fish
i posted a few elements this was a great
dish right here you know there was this
whole argument that i posted this
picture to my facebook as well
these look like just shrimp but they're
really not it's really i mean listen i
guess it kind of is shrimp but it's a
little bit different they call these
langotinos and um you know it's very
simple it's just you put the lemon on
it's paprika and and salt and oil you
could call them prawns yeah exactly
and um
somebody on my uh somebody on my
facebook said
there is no point in seasoning the
shells none of the flavor gets through
and it's like hold on a second that
first of all the shell is not sealed
like the entire underside by the legs
the the stuff is getting in the stuff is
getting in
and i found it
really really offensive that someone
said there's no point in seasoning
shrimp because you don't eat the shell
and none of the flavor it's crazy these
were the most flavorful prawns that i've
ever had
um
and i did not eat the shells
uh and what else
oh i had a big garden haul when i got
back yeah all this stuff was waiting for
me
i guess it rained enough so that things
didn't die i had a bunch of tomatoes
two jalapenos two strawberries
two different types of pepper i actually
don't know what this middle pepper is it
might be
i don't know what it is this this one's
a cubanelle
four green tomatoes for whatever reason
this type of tomato it won't ripen on
the vine so i just clip them and then in
a week it'll be bright yellow these are
lemon cukes beautiful cukes i've never
grown lemon cukes before
but really really it's just so crisp
it's crazy
and then two eggplants and then what i
did um yesterday actually
is some of my lettuces
it's just over for the lettuce
so i pulled some lettuces
and then i planted based on my zone i
checked in of course with kevin from
epic gardening about it i planted
cabbage i planted a couple types of
carrots including heirloom carrots that
are orange on the outside red in the
middle it's like an old school carrot
from the
i think it came to the us in the 1920s
it changed its name to sound less jewish
interestingly but yeah it came to the
u.s in the 1920s
and
also two different types of beets the
the kind of like typical red beet from
the 1800s
and then also um
a beet that is orange on the outside but
like spackled yellow on the inside very
very interesting beat
from the standpoint of root vegetables
so i'll keep you guys informed about
that starting those from seed which i
think is i think it's going to be great
i think it will be absolutely fantastic
um
okay
so it's lance versus dp one ball or two
balls geez
so glad to have you back david sir
appreciate your knowledge of cone to ice
cream ratio yeah you need the right
ratio it's just crazy
gates looks like an attractive man made
on a budget
i blame the joy for today's incident in
dc
yeah okay so let's talk about that so
there was there was a bomb threat in dc
i still haven't learned much about it
but the guy almost the guy was live
streaming and it was like a bizarre
manifesto from inside the car listen to
this
if you blow my truck up man hey
seems like an actor out of central
casting unfortunately this is real
it's on you joe
i'm ready to die for calls
and brother if you said if you could do
anything to save one life one life
you said you'd do it is he saying life
or laugh
must be life right
you got a chance
i want to go home sunday
i want to go home and see my wife this
guy's going to be in prison the rest of
his life right i mean do we know
we're living in a free country joe
choice yours
[Music]
you want to shoot me
and take the chance of blowing up two
and a half city blocks
because that toolbox full
money nitro it's full
did he say his lemonade truck
i don't want to die joe i want to go
home
[Music]
yeah
um here's more i guess
the south's here
there's five of us spreading all cost
you a little they say part here
yeah
and as people are pointing out in part
of the part of the uh speech
uh call it a speech maybe is a bit much
in part of the the screed
he talks about how
he and his wife didn't have or were
denied insurance coverage and it's like
dude
what
you're a trump guy like it just doesn't
even make sense you know just does it
ever everything about it doesn't make
sense it's tragic in so many different
ways
um
it's it's it's truly a truly a tragedy
we'll learn more about it
um
oh let me thank a few more members
before this starts just i can't believe
what's happening on the website it can
barely keep up new members using the uh
anniversary code 16 for 16. luke rue
castle number one
james henry number two
luke rue castle with a second membership
number three
graham curnu number four
john ellis number five tommy get tommy
gedinet number six
mike reed is number seven kareem utley
is number eight patrick denihan is
number nine
cynthia bricker is number 10 and wendy
malloy is number 11
putting us at 54
but that's before
i add the twitch subs thanks to jamin
rowe smith a danish joint
try kill eric
flea girl
the freak easy air
splash mock
and
i think that's it okay that's five more
putting us at 59. we are standing by for
a pretty poorly attended the
demographics seem to be mostly older
mostly white
the room is two-thirds empty
let's listen social media
they've been talking about what's been
going on in afghanistan of course with
the withdrawal of our troops there and
also uh the fallout of pulling out of
afghanistan plus we'll talk about
election integrity that has been one of
the topics integrity
integrity of nuclear
um
cepheid
very much so
hello david ryan and long time listener
from central wisconsin
you should visit for the cheese and stay
because your car won't start defeat
rj2022
sir there should be a discussion about
how cobit isn't free you still have to
pay for medical bills whether you die
from it or not so much freedom
david would you ever play dungeons and
dragons i mean maybe
at what point does spreading false
information about vaccines that causes
death becomes illegal and should it
i don't know how you make it illegal i
think you you ban it based on terms of
service
too bad bomb robots can't administer 10
milligrams of hal doll
sir i watch you both and meet kevin
every day i just want to give you a
strong and powerful shout out to kevin
for governor of california
i would have him on to talk about his
candidacy
about the california recall vote no for
the recall second option vote for kevin
paffraff or else our governor will be
nutcase larry elder
i believe larry elder today was accused
of something pretty serious
uh i'm not even going to say it in case
it's not true
but it's not looking great for larry
elder
dave there are comments on celeb heights
that peg you at five six because you
look two inches shorter than joe rogan
no i was taller than i'm taller than
rogan there's a push to get you listed
on ch
because you've lied about being five
nine
what the hell
hold on what is that
celeb heights
david
pakman celeb height wiki is that it
it doesn't seem to have my height on it
um
i'm not seeing that
but no i i i recall being taller than
rogan let's see here david pakman joe
rogan
um
no no no no no what's going on is i'm
standing behind rogan from the
standpoint of the camera
and he's he's closer to the camera like
see how i mean i know that he's bulkier
than me but even his head looks way
bigger he's standing like a foot in
front of me
um
[Music]
yeah
anyway
uh not that it matters
okay holy [ __ ]
all right let's um let's move on
yeah who even cares who's taller there's
a bizarre thing to go down
thanks to boatsy bloke
for the twitch sub number 60 very much
appreciate it also thank you to laurie
minden
who just signed up on my website with
the code 16 for 16. if you're just
joining us we are about to see a
completely meaningless and pathetic
rally with members of congress marjorie
taylor greene and matthew gates
the room is
sort of like half empty
and it's very very sad but i'm just
trying to remember how to stream because
saturday is a trump rally and we're
going to be having a big big stream
uh oh
celebhites.com let's see
let's see
okay
so do i type pacman
no i guess i'm not on the website yet
all right who cares
let's get away from that okay um
oh people are asking what's the why is
the coupon code oh yeah so for people
who are just joining monday was the 16th
anniversary of the david pakman show
it's crazy to believe i started the show
when i was in fifth grade
and we've reached our 16th anniversary
to celebrate that 16th anniversary
we did a coupon code on monday 16 for 16
1 6 for 16. we've never done a discount
this big you can get a year for 16 bucks
you can get a month for a dollar sixty
uh i think
and people are just going crazy they're
ripping clocks off the wall desperate to
sign up
why the clock has to be off the wall to
sign up i don't know amanda bennett just
took advantage and she is the newest
member number 62 today
and um i really appreciate that you can
take advantage of it maybe we'll keep
the code going until until the the rally
on saturday
david did you see the story about larry
david yelling at dershowitz yes oh and
what i especially love about that story
is i've been going to martha's vineyard
for for quite some time and i regularly
go to exactly the little place where it
happened it's a really quiet place let
me see if i can find it so i was
imagining
like
it was probably a really weird weird
scene
here's the article it's just absolutely
perfect
uh okay larry david screamed at alan
dershowitz at a grocery store to even
call it a grocery store as an
exaggeration
okay
um
a page six spy spotted the harvard law
professor who was once like larry david
a fully paid-up member of the democratic
cool kids
bumping into the comic on the porch of
the island's picturesque convenience
store and community hub chillmark
general store i've waited on that porch
due to coveted regulations they were
letting in only three people at a time
and found their exchange so bizarre that
they wrote it down to remember it
page six strongly recommends that
readers enjoy the following while
playing the curb your enthusiasm theme
in their heads dershowitz says we can
still talk larry
and larry david says no no we really
can't i saw you i saw you with your arm
around pompeo it's disgusting
and dershowitz says he's my former
student i greet all of my former
students that way i can't greet my
former students
it's disgusting your whole enclave it's
disgusting you're disgusting
added the stun source larry walks away
alan takes off his t-shirt to reveal
another t-shirt underneath that says
it's the constitution stupid
we're told durst drove off in an old
dirty volvo
i'm guessing he just keeps that on the
island for when he's there i'm sure he
has some other car
um it's a curb episode in and of itself
it's crazy it's a crazy story
um
okay
here is a
um
here's something from my interview with
when i interviewed mike lindell this is
sort of like a stylized version of all
of my reactions during the inter
interview
troll game on fleek
i like it
i like it
and
this is another one
when your friend at work says they
figured out a no-lose way to make money
with the stock market pretty good
i like that
so thank you appreciate that always
great to get stuff from the audience
let's listen a little bit to what's
happening at this rally which will be
meaningless by the way thought to define
that that uh order and a lot of uh
superintendents around the state are
pretty much defined defining uh
define the governor on that as well so
we'll see how that plays out so let us
know where you're watching us right now
and all your kids
by the way
speaking of uh his inability to to
pronounce that correctly
i this is on today's podcast
but i found it so funny
um what's today the 19th
and
let's see regeneron
tell me if you noticed something a
little weird in this clip
build these
these mono colonial antibodies
oh that's great mono colonial
they're not monoclonal anymore these are
monocle it's an issue of colonization
quite frankly the the antibodies will
colonize your entire thing
mono colon colonial
um very very strange
should randy rainbow take down his
andrew cuomo love ballad video haven't
seen it
peter says i've met dave in person he's
five six max
no way in hell
no way in hell
um listen i admit that i lie about being
five nine but i'm five eight
okay i'm not five six
does this donation go to trump's legal
defense fund i heard his troubles in
georgia doubled
it that yes maybe
maybe
that could be true
i want to say thank you to andre bavaria
who just signed up via twitch prime
13 months
and says glad you're back how was your
holiday in europe it was great why don't
you stay here with us and escape that
madness you're about to stream yeah i
almost got stuck there because my
girlfriend had two positive covet tests
um but i made it back how
the story is on yesterday's bonus show
very important story
i tested positively from the standpoint
of negative
um
and i think i have something related to
this convalescent plasma
and then i see the disinfectant is there
a way we can do something like that
uh by
injection inside supposing we hit the
body with a tremendous uh very powerful
light donate plasma apply
light and heat to cure
donate plasma today please supposing you
brought the light inside the body
convalescent plasma yeah so that's that
story
um
okay
i do miss plasma i do miss plot every
every freaking day it's like you had to
wonder no one's saying you know sir it's
plasma
every single day
all right a few other new members i want
to say thank you to on we
has signed up with the coupon code 16
for 16.
patrick thornton just signed up with a
coupon code 16 for 16. nick mascara is a
new member
matt smiley has just signed up jamison
ferranosi
has just signed up
rebecca schulman
dwayne
hiltner is a new member lee herr has
just signed up
ryan larkin is a new member very much
appreciate that guys putting us at 70 a
really strong showing let's see what's
going on they're already i guess a half
hour late here and many many seats to
fill is this a church do we know there
was a little bit of a line we came in
here earlier there's as you would
imagine there is a security checkpoint
to get into this building so
you gotta go through that i would
imagine
that slows up the crowd
slightly coming into this building but
one thing looks like they have seats for
about if i'm just eyeballing it right
now probably about 300 people probably
uh and i would say maybe 45 40 is filled
right now so it's gonna be a kind of a
slow go getting in here and of course
there's some seats blocked off in front
that you're probably taking a look at
now that are i would say likely reserved
for some vip they're probably there's
definitely really important people going
to this hey margie taylor green was at
the iowa state fair and i saw her on her
social media doing some pull-ups there
pumping out several pull-ups out i might
add very impressive by that so she made
an appearance there super impressed yeah
she was able to do a 45 year old woman
doing two pull-ups is really i mean it's
a sight to behold um okay so we're
standing by and as i said earlier i'm
not planning on streaming very late i'm
still on on sort of europe time
um sort of it's sort of like midnight
for me right now
so i'm probably only going to stream
another 30 to 45 minutes hopefully this
thing actually starts but we're just
getting back into the stream of things
i'm hoping to be fully acclimated
to my time zone by the trump rally on
saturday
oh my god it looks like there's kids
here is this a kid
sort of
actually that might be a 25 year old
woman i can't tell
um oh here's a kid that's definitely a
kid right
yeah it's crazy a kid would want to go
to this bizarre
my pillow is becoming the corporate face
of the right wing if we're not careful
we may have to worry about the pillow
industrial complex in 2024. well said if
i donate plasma to the clinic will trump
buy me a free cup of cabfefe
i tested negative
from the standpoint of positive that's
marjorie taylor pacman
sir are you taller than steven destiny
bonnell ii
i don't know
i don't know
keep the glasses toss the contacts you
babe the problem is they reflect my my
very powerful studio lights see look at
that
hold on there we go
oh my god it's like bitcoin
look at me
can someone steal that that's crazy
anyway uh yeah if they didn't if they
didn't i could just wear glasses with no
frame no lenses i guess
okay um
he said ammonium nitrate okay yep it's
time to release the jewish space lasers
david remember 5 8 is not short it is
average
exactly
exactly all right let's let's yeah i got
away from voicemails but i did want to
play a few more
um just a couple other quick thank yous
thanks to yonah
sorry it's not yonah
johanna pennington
is a new member there's marjorie covett
green
um also thanks to joshua terrell for the
membership taylor melville
esther lethrem
blake sheridan and andrew peterson
76 today
looks like things are about to get going
trump has come to town and that's what
people uh indeed want to see i had a few
more people walking in now it seems like
they might have i guess marjorie taylor
green that was marjorie taylor green
right sitting in the front row
maybe there's introduction speeches
first i don't know
what a weird event i'm just trying to
think like
what's going on in these people's lives
that this is what they're doing is it
that boring in des moines iowa
where this is what you go to
big tranche of people coming in a cohort
thanks to dave b for subscribing for the
first time on twitch appreciate that
um a lot of resubs okay so so i meant to
get back to the voicemails let's see if
we can get a couple more in
before uh before before things get going
i think i'm not like buying this whole
like non-violent strategy
because i think in order
to say
that
um
you're doing something non-violent
that kind of suggests that like
there should be some sort of reparation
for
man she leaves a lot of voicemails
so um
i was studying a bit about these like
personality archetypes that people have
and i have like the same one that um
benjamin has it's like the architect
and um hold on what's going on here
address impromptu usa being addressed
here which is always
nice is that desantis oh no no no talk
to me for a second come on up here
you know every event what a weird event
a lot of mental illness here
so i was looking at the economies um as
far as like what's who's like the most
competitive economy
and then like which ones are like
growing the fastest
man these voicemails are going nowhere
so i really feel like um
now that there's like transgender
surgeries and there's like
girl
boys that are
girls that are actually boys
i feel like kind of like
it should count as murder for the men
i just don't believe that like it's just
an accident you know what's not an act i
mean it's all so incoherent
so i feel like um like a conversation
about abortion is necessary um for
people to have
maybe i don't know like college or
something like or um maybe like high
school would be appropriate
um i just
um i did get one two three four five six
seven eight nine 10 11 12 calls in a row
from the drunk chicago guy do we want to
listen to drunk chicago guy
you know what mr pacman i
sir
sir i i never
i never barely ever agree with joe rogel
but
he he has a point
why don't we deal why why have we been
in afghanistan and iraq for 20 years
why why are we why aren't we dealing
with north korea and people in china
okay then he called back
i i i love watching this russian guy too
but what does he mean there's nothing to
do with it you can't do anything about
north korea
he came straight we could
we can okay then he called back
how
how is an invasion on north korea an
invasion on china
it doesn't even make sense to me to
can you explain this
okay another one
guys
he does seem to be getting more drunk
with each call that is that's a that's a
fair observation um playing each other
for afghanistan failure
missouri gun
it's crazy how the term missouri gun
couple allows us to identify exactly who
he's talking about
i use stuff again because
because that joe rogers thing just
i've been watching the news i watched
the news
all right called back again ten minutes
later the guy that i i i like i like
listen though you're the guy you hired
while you're on vacation and staying
he's saying the exam
he's saying everything i just said
he's saying everything i just said
ah
i'm not that smart
but jesus christ
you know what
heavens to pass these stuff oh man
called back again
i'm listening to a slightly smarter
sober individual
he's like he's literally just saying
everything i just said to you
this happened 20 years ago
yep here's another one
am i in a force or like a fourth or
fifth dimension of another world
is this really freaking going on
this is
insane okay
yes i'm quitting i'm i'm drinking the
rest of my vodka
and i have a 40 and and another true
this is a disease guys this is alcohol
this is a disease
normally this
freaking [ __ ]
angers me so much it makes me want to
drink but this time
i'm quitting
i'm good good
i'm putting never all of it
no will not weed not weed no but i ain't
quitting alcohol
i am
you you know yep so he definitely needs
help
um
couple other calls
hey david b dog here i just watched your
interview with mike pillow
i really enjoyed it but i i like how
mike pillow is catching on by the way i
was wondering why you didn't ask him a
very important question dog and that
question is
how did he get away with stealing
the font from my pillow
from exhibit and the mtv show pimp my
ride
thanks pack dog i'll take my answers off
the air i don't have any answers for you
because i don't don't even know what
he's talking about we're continuing
this is like these could these are all
people calling from blocked numbers so
it could be
hal doll holly it could be drunk guy you
know we just don't know
like on one hand
like i can see why people have a lot of
respect for trump um like
it just seems like he has a really good
hand in life
and then for him to like go up and suck
it up that bad i'm just like mortified
because i'm like that looks like the
easiest hand in the world
like literally like all you have to do
is like stand there and wave and just
closure okay
oh boy this is troy york call
calling on a completely garbled
completely garbled connection while i
was on vacation
um
[Music]
what is troy talking about hold on
there's like the garble at the beginning
is just perfect that's an unbelie it's
just completely it's just nothing
i'm watching kyle
oh kyle kalinski i i heard
this
i'm a friend of his what i'm watching on
his viewpoint of afghanistan
i'm starting to wonder
either
wow completely garbled
well so i just watched a video of mike
dyson he just
does an excellent job demonstrating that
the liberal media propaganda all right
well then go go talk to mark dice it's
funny um troy knew exactly like when my
vacation started when it ended
uh
for all of his disgust with this show
he's very very much paying attention to
our exact schedule
so there's like two problems i'm having
at least
two different like kind of identities of
the conservative side
um so one side is like the women
and then um the other side is the men so
it like doesn't go without saying for
the women like what you should do and
what you should not do
um
like if your dad okay
so one of the issues that i'm having is
like all the donald trump support
because it's like
i totally agree with like conservative
viewpoints but when it comes to
like my clients and stuff like that like
i usually choose like their side she has
clients that's wild
so i've been noticing that um i've been
reading her uh substitute
um
increments like newscasts this is just
this is just horrible
steve gregory here david
it's
crazy none of donald trump's kids
have been brought in by the southern
district of new york
donald trump hasn't been brought in by
the southern district of new york yet
the case is against him for rape
haven't gotten
his behind into court yet
david
please
push this
and challenge and shame
the attorney general if necessary what
is he doing yep and i think they left
another one
they gave it um oh no this one's yours i
have a real stupid co-host or guest
filling in
um he's talking about marjory taylor
green and video
talking about how she's making
uh news that there is no coping
surge
well the left and idiots like him and
yourself and others
have been saying for years months
that there is no man troy's just gotten
really boring really really boring
in fact man this is clark craney
did he say clark kringle
it's troy yorke if you can't tell i'm
going to
push back against your cables you could
allow the co-host and fill in for you
uh while you're on vacation and just
push back in general
of your vaccine mandates
and your demands and lies about the
pharmaceutical industry
and what the media is attempting to
harass people
all right let's see what's going on at
the rally
of what happened in the 2020
presidential election
and what the big lie is the big lie is
the big lie
and he showed you what the results were
recorded on election day he also showed
you what the real results were what and
of course there was so many so much talk
about p-caps and all the data that was
transferred uh during the election
a lot of that evidence came out there's
a lot of cyber experts that were the p
caps whoa question his findings and
which which is that's why he brought him
there to do just that so
we were there we reported it i really
think it's a pivotal uh broadcast it's
shocking that there's a warm-up guy at a
gates green rally isn't it it's about
the election and whatever state you live
on i'll give you a great example
from 2016 to 2020 in the state of
pennsylvania republicans out
registered democrats 12
excuse me 20 to one
out registered new voters republican
democrats 20 years they seem to think
that just saying things is evidence zolt
said the a complete opposite the swing
and what reality and what they say
happened is huge
none of it makes sense none of it this
is like a car crash i i can't look away
it's so crazy
[Music]
all right i guess here we go
we just lost the audio
[Music]
is this christian music
[Music]
real quick let me thank a few more good
people um paul keith just signed up on
my website so did paul santos also want
to say thank you to kachna
paul hilton is a new member everett
vincent is a new member john deeds just
signed up
so did martin vaughn these are these are
really great people but we are going to
listen to marjorie taylor green just for
a little bit
be here with you
we have a lot to talk about
well thank you for coming tonight i know
school's getting started and there's a
lot going on but i really appreciate you
coming out and seeing my great uh great
friend matt gates and like really really
we adore you we love you we're grateful
for you
and we work for you what
she represents georgia but it's not that
way it's not that way for every
person that we work with as a matter of
fact unfortunately
a lot of our colleagues and a lot of
people in washington
have forgotten that this is a government
for the people and by the people
nice dribble it's pablum
but i'm there
to remind them
[Applause]
you see i'm no different than you
as a matter of fact when you see me in
washington
it's you in washington
because president trump is my favorite
president
that's disturbing and he won the
election oh
boy
people are standing because she's just
straight up lying for four years what
putting america first and putting
americans first looks like and i'm so
grateful for him and his administration
and all the people that worked with him
and defended him
like congressman gates that you'll hear
from after me
[Music]
but you see there's a civil war going on
in the gop and i'm very much going to
talk about that tonight
and i'll tell you why because it's time
to bring it out in the open
and we need to discuss the issues
discuss issues now
there's the old guard
the bushes the cheyneys the paul ryans
the mitch mcconnells
the neocons
very much wanting to take back control
they want to tell you that president
trump was just a blip on the radar we'll
see they want to tell you all
that the passion and the energy you feel
and all those trump signs and the
american flags and for the first time
someone was talking about the american
worker and someone was saying bring back
these jobs from overseas and someone was
saying build a wall and defend our
borders all pretty stupid things to say
either because they're bad ideas or they
ignore economic reality back to the blue
we need to support law enforcement
[Music]
they're super supportive of the officers
from the trump riots right guys
and we support our military
well they want to tell you all
that no no no you need to calm down this
whole america first thing yes that's
great and we like it as republicans and
but you know what we just need to move
on past trump
stop talking about this election stuff
don't talk about sh
[Applause]
this is a repulsive woman
get to him in a minute i don't have very
nice things to say tonight
i'm going to talk about my party first
yes i will absolutely well i got a phone
number for you guys i need you guys i
need you all to write it down i need you
to put it in the in your notes in your
phone as a matter of fact this is a con
these people don't have notes
this is the congressional hotline this
is the switchboard
and this is how you call congress
you can call my office first you should
explain how phones work probably office
we love to hear from y'all
as a matter of fact people call my
office every single day and i'm grateful
for it
you can call any of my colleagues you
can call nancy pelosi if you want nancy
pelosi
[Music]
oh you should call her
she needs to hear from you uh n a n t z
y
p u h l o z i nancy pelosi
you can call any of them
what about jerry nadler
adam schiff
them
i want you to
their people call my office
oh they do they call all the time
marjorie how dare you say trump won the
election
they actually revel in their idiocy
that's it that's part of the problem
actually two two four three one two one
two oh two
two two four
three one two one
now here's the deal ladies and gentlemen
and everyone that's watching
you see the federal government
operates with your tax dollars that you
work very hard for and all of those tax
dollars pay our salaries my salary and
everyone else's salaries as a matter of
fact those hard-earned tax dollars that
the irs makes sure that you send in
guess what
those tax tax dollars pay for the
buildings they pay for the light they
pay for the bills the lights
they pay for every single part now she
seems to be explaining how buildings
work remodel your kitchen would you let
that contractor tear your kitchen apart
rip your cabinets out put your kitchen
sink out in the front yard
and then walk away and not finish the
job but make you pay for it
no
well america
you're allowing the federal government
to destroy our country i mean if you
hire someone just for the demo part that
it may be for them to have our borders
completely invaded every single day with
over two hundred thousand illegals
every month
fentanyl coming across the border
yes
terrorists are coming across the border
and guess what now
this administration has abandoned
americans in afghanistan
it was trump's plan
when nancy pelosi drags us all back up
to washington do you know what we're
voting on
the green new deal
no they're calling it infrastructure 1.2
trillion dollars
it's not infrastructure
you know what it is it's step one of the
green new deal 7.5
billion dollars in that
infrastructure
it's going to pay china
to work on an infrastructure grid this
is a really disjointed speech it just
it's just what is she even talking about
yeah did you know that no you didn't
know that because there was a bunch of
republicans in the senate that voted for
this because it's bipartisan
infrastructure
well i'm sorry if republicans
are calling paying china
any money
to do anything in the united states that
has anything to do with our
infrastructure then that is china first
and america last
and that is not the kind of
bipartisanship we want in the united
states government
[Applause]
china
and then there's the 3.5 trillion dollar
budget
that is the green new deal
that aoc gets to create something called
the climate core oh man it's her antifa
jobs program
for all her little friends how many
people in this crowd even have any idea
what she's talking about like she's
obviously lying and mixing together
unrelated issues but are these even
issues people in the crowd know a damn
thing about sir that they're going to
create to make sure that you're not
putting out too much carbon fraud
because you're a bunch of climate
centers did you know that
yeah you're climate centers
so our government the democrats i'm
absolutely bought in on bernie sanders
plan for america
aoc's plan for america with the green
new deal
that is going to force all vehicles sold
in the united states by 2030
to be electric vehicles that sounds
great
by the way i thought it was 50 percent
it also converts buses to electric
vehicles that's fantastic series to
electric vehicles
and will mandate by law for all of you
to eventually
you can't drive your gas or diesel car
truck you have to drive it this can't
just be a georgia like every word is
bizarre
it's this one example is i is it diesel
i've never heard diesel pronounced
diesel it's because it's something every
american can understand whether you're a
republican or a democrat or an i don't
care you can understand this because
most people have a car or a truck or
have a friend that does
now here's the situation
the government should never control the
private business sector of our country
they control the gas markets already
through subsidies taxes i mean is she
saying they should get out of that too
americans to switch to electric vehicles
now i want you to think this through yes
that would be great
thank you china controls is she trying
to act as though the components for gas
powered vehicles aren't made in other
countries as well battery market
china is 75
75 the battery market
so start making them here
by incentivizing it ever pass a policy
that forces us to depend on communist
china
for our energy needs
why would they do that we know what
happens with china we get it's weird to
be like you know i have an electric
vehicle
and i'm in the process of getting solar
so ultimately i'll be charging my
electric vehicle
with solar power
and
because maybe the battery had components
made in china
i'm i'm now i'm that's chinese energy
that's power i mean just it doesn't make
any sense it's very stupid to drive
electric vehicles and you get to supply
the batteries oh you know what china you
get to build our infrastructure grid
with electric vehicle charging stations
that is what we are voting on next week
next week we are voting on that
guys i have solar panels i'm a communist
about oh i'm probably going to vote for
the infrastructure deal
you call them right now and tell them no
you tell them to vote no to the
infrastructure deal
because it is step one
to the green new deal you tell them to
vote no to the i wish i hope
which is the green new deal you tell
them to vote no
and here's how serious i am about this
this is another confusion the
infrastructure bill that's being debated
it's not the green new deal it just it
just has it's not the green new deal
it's not kind of a thing they don't do
they usually let the staff do it
but i actually read them
and i read them and i believe what they
say because i know what happens when we
vote on them
and this is everything this is nancy
pelosi's legacy this is what she's going
for
they want it
i'm so serious about stopping these two
bills here's how here's how serious i am
i have said that i will primary
any republican
that votes for the infrastructure or the
budget
that's a real tough threat guys wow
[Applause]
as a matter of fact i'm so serious my
leadership pack has raised over 250 000
and by the way that sounds like exactly
the type of chaos the left could benefit
from because americans like you are
donating
sas pac.com s-a-s-s-p-a-c-dot-com
if you want to help me
fund a primary against a feckless weak
republican that is going to help the
democrats pass the green new deal donate
to sasspac.com all right that sounds
interesting
and i'm not playing
and here's why i have a great life
i don't have to be doing this but i'm
doing it because i have three children
that i oh my god more than anyone on
this planet the last thing i really want
is to be here with you people right now
but i'm doing it my kids need a future
and their future should not involve
being slaves to china
their future should not involve
socialist programs
their future should not involve a
government that leaves americans
stranded in a foreign country china
that that is not the future of america
that i want for anyone's children
this is the greatest country in the
world
it is it's the greatest country in the
world and it's only going to stay great
if we all work together and keep it that
way and that's why if even after joe
biden has destroyed everything it's
still the best in the world it seems
we've got some buffer call them and hold
them accountable
because you hired them
you hired them and that means let them
know how you feel you don't have to say
it mean you don't have to say it nasty
but you have to tell them directly
i want you to vote for this we don't
want you to vote for this
if you want a donation from me mr and
mrs american citizen
then you need to do the job correctly
otherwise we're not donating
we're not voting for you
stand back and step accountable please
i'm asking you to help me hold them
accountable
no
crowd's not super into it
now let's talk about joe biden
[Music]
i cannot believe i cannot believe
that we have a president and any
president it shouldn't matter what party
they are
the president of the united states of
america should never
ever leave americans behind like he has
done
no man left what about the 300 million
americans trump left behind with his
failed covet leadership our people
how can we trust him
even if even if this is a president that
we didn't vote for that we didn't
support no american president should do
this to his people
none
there are thousands of americans trapped
over there under the terrorist taliban
regime
and it's not just the taliban it's isis
too
and al qaeda
radical islamic terrorism sharia law
that she's just throwing out buzzwords
all right guys listen it's 8 30 and it
is my bedtime i'm still on uh europe
time and it's feeling very very late i
did want to come in and do do a bunch of
things but really we've got our big
stream happening on saturday and i hope
everybody will be back donald trump
supposedly getting reinstated as
president saturday night in alabama many
people believe that
it's a very strange thing to believe but
many people believe that and it's
extremely extremely unusual
so uh thank you for joining me
we are hopefully gonna take some calls
on saturday i'll be starting before the
uh trump rally it's great to be back
it's great to be back and we've got so
many things going on so we'll see
everybody very soon you're not gonna i
would say go and watch this on a
different channel
don't don't do it just do something else
read a book play a video game watch a
movie
um check out the tv show counterpart i
just finished watching it it's great to
be back
uh this is not worth our time and we are
calling it a day